Al parecer tengo 18 minutos
para convencerlos de que la historia va en una dirección, como una flecha.
Que en un sentido fundamental, es bueno;
que la flecha apunta hacia algo positivo.
Cuando la gente de TED se me acercó por primera vez para que diera esta optimista charla...
(Risas)
fue antes de que la caricatura de Mahoma disparara protestas globales.
Fue antes de que la gripe aviar llegara a Europa.
Fue antes de que Hamas ganara las elecciones palestinas,
provocando varias contramedidas por parte de Israel.
Y seamos sinceros, de haber sabido cuando me pidieron que diera esta charla optimista
que mientras daba la charla optimista,
ocurriría el apocalipsis...
(Risas)
podría haber dicho: "¿Importará si hablo sobre otra cosa?"
Pero OK, no lo hice. Así que aquí estamos. Haré lo que pueda. Haré lo que pueda.
Debo advertirles:
el sentido en que mi visión del mundo es optimista siempre ha sido algo sutil,
incluso hasta esquiva.
(Risas)
La forma en que puedo ser optimista e inspirador...
bueno, siempre ha habido una especie de aspecto sombrío
en cómo trato de ser optimista, por lo tanto si la inspiración sombría,
(Risas)
si la inspiración sombría no es un contrasentido, me temo que es
a lo más que ustedes pueden aspirar. Bueno, hoy... si es que lo logro.
Veré que puedo hacer, ¿vale?
Ahora, de alguna forma,
la afirmación de que la historia tiene una sola dirección no es tan controvertida.
Pero si sólo hablamos de estructura social,
bueno, claramente se ha convertido en algo más complejo;
en poco más de los últimos diez mil años ha alcanzado niveles cada vez superiores.
Y de hecho, mantiene una larga
tendencia que antecede a los seres humanos, ¿sí?
que la evolución biológica hizo por nosotros.
Porque lo que ocurrió al principio, esta cosa se encierra a si misma en una celula,
y luego las celulas empiezan a agruparse en sociedades.
Eventualmente se unen tanto, que forman organismos multicelulares,
y luego organismos multicelulares complejos; ellos forman sociedades.
Pero en algún punto, uno de estos organismos multicelulares
hace algo totalmente increíble con esta cosa, y es que
empieza un segundo tipo de evolución: la evolución cultural.
E increíblemente, esa evolución sostiene la trayectoria
establecida por la evolución biológica para alcanzar mayor complejidad.
Por evolución cultural entendemos la evolución de las ideas.
Muchos de ustedes han oído del término "memes". Le presto mucha atención
a la evolución de la tecnología, asi que, bueno,
una de las primeras cosas que tenemos fue una pequeña hacha manual.
Las generaciones pasan y alguien dice, oye, ¿por qué no la ponemos en un palo?
(Risas)
Sencillamente fascina a los pequeños.
Lo mejor después de un videojuego.
Puede que esto no sea muy impresionante,
pero lo evolución tecnológica es progresiva, así que pasan otros 10 o 20.000 años
y la tecnología armamentista nos trae al ahora.
(Risas)
Impresionante. Y el ritmo de la evolución tecnológica acelera,
y apenas un cuarto de siglo después de eso, obtienes esto, ¿no?
(Risas)
Y esto.
Lo siento, era un chiste fácil, pero quería encontrar la forma
de volver a la idea del apocalipsis en desarrollo,
y creí que con ello lo lograría.
(Risas).
OK. Entonces, lo que podría suceder con este apocalipsis en desarrollo,
es el colapso de la organización social global.
Pero antes permítanme recordales el tremendo esfuerzo que significó traernos adonde estamos,
al borde de una verdadera organización social global.
Originalmente, las sociedades más complejas eran los pueblos de cazadores-recolectores.
Stonehenge es lo que queda de un jefatura,
que es lo que resulta de la invención de la agricultura: un régimen político de varios pueblos
con un gobierno centralizado.
Con la invención de la escritura, empiezan a aparecer ciudades. Esto es un poco borroso, lo que me gusta
porque lo hace parecerse a un organismo unicelular y nos recuerda
cuántos niveles la organización orgánica ya ha superado
para llegar a este punto. Y luego, ya saben, llegamos a los imperios.
Pero bueno, quiero enfatizar que una organización social puede trascender límites políticos.
Esto es la Ruta de la Seda conectando al Imperio Chino y el Imperio Romano.
Entonces había una complejidad social que alcanzaba todo el continente,
aunque ningún régimen político hiciera nada similar. Hoy, hay naciones estados.
El tema es que, obviamente, hay colaboración y organización que va
más allá de las fronteras nacionales.
Esta es una fotografía de la tierra durante la noche,
y la muestro sólo porque es bonita.
De alguna forma transmite la sensación de que esto es un sistema integrado.
Bueno, pues he explicado este desarrollo de complejidad en cuanto a algo
llamado suma no nula.
Brevemente, asumiendo que no todos han consultado la bibliografía,
la idea clave es la distinción entre juegos suma cero, en que las correlaciones
son inversas: siempre hay un ganador y un perdedor.
Y los juegos de suma no nula en que las correlaciones pueden ser positivas.
Por ejemplo, en el tenis, usualmente es ganar-perder,
siempre resulta en una suma cero-cero, pero si juegas dobles
tu pareja está en mismo barco que tú,
por lo que juegas un juego suma no nula con ella.
Es o para mejor, o para peor, ¿no?
Muchas formas de suma no nula en el campo de la economía y otros
de la vida diaria llevan a la cooperación.
Mi argumento es que, bueno, básicamente
los juegos de suma no nula siempre han formado parte de la vida.
Existían en las sociedades cazadoras-recolectoras,
pero luego a partir de la evolución tecnológica, surgen nuevas formas de tecnología
que facilitan o promueven los juegos de suma no nula,
involucrando cada vez a más gente sobre territorios cada vez más grandes.
La estructura social se acomoda a esta posibilidad y
para aprovechar este potencial productivo, aparecen las ciudades,
y obtienes todos los juegos de suma no nula que no pensamos
que se estén jugando en todo el mundo.
Por ejemplo, ¿alguna vez han pensado cuando compran un auto,
cuántas personas en cuántos continentes distintos contribuyeron
a fabricar ese auto? En la práctica, con todos ellos
estás jugando un juego de suma no nula.
Es decir, claramente hay muchos de ellos.
Ahora, esto parece una visión del mundo intrínsicamente optimista,
porque cuando piensas en no cero, piensas en ganar-ganar,
y eso es bueno. Bueno, existen algunas razones
de por qué no es instrínsicamente optimista.
En primer lugar, se acomoda: no niega la existencia
de guerras de explotación injustas.
Pero existe una razón más fundamental
de por qué no es intrínsicamente optimista, porque un juego de suma no nula
lo único que te indica con certeza es que el resultado tendrá una correlación para mejor o peor.
No predice necesariamente un resultado ganar-ganar.
Por lo tanto, de alguna forma, la pregunta es, ¿cómo
es que soy optimista en cuanto a la historia? Y la respuesta es,
en primer lugar, creo que de media la gente ha jugado sus cartas
para alcanzar más resultados ganar-ganar que perder-perder. De media,
creo que la historia es netamente positiva dentro de los juegos de suma no nula.
Y la prueba de esto es lo que más me asombra,
lo que más me impresiona y más me anima,
y es que la historia tiene una dimensión moral,
que existe una flecha moral. Hemos visto progreso moral a través del tiempo.
Hace 2.500 años, los miembros de una ciudad estado griega
consideraban que los miembros de otra ciudad estado griega eran subhumanos
y los trataban de esa forma. Y entonces apareció esta revolución moral
y decidieron que en realidad, todos los griegos eran seres humanos.
Eran sólo los persas los que no eran totalmente humanos
y no merecían un trato amable.
Pero hay que darles crédito, pues esto era progreso. Y actualmente,
hemos visto más progreso. Creo... deseo, que casi todos los acá presentes afirmaría
que todas las personas en cualquier lugar son seres humanos,
que merecen un trato decente,
sin importar su raza o religión, a menos que hayan hecho algo horrible.
Y hay que leer la historia antigua para entender la importancia de esta revolución.
Pues bien, ésta no era la visión prevalente
hace algunos miles de años, lo que atribuyo a esta dinámica de suma no nula.
Creo que ésa es la razón por la que actualmente hay tanta tolerancia hacia las
nacionalidades, etnias y religiones. Si ustedes me preguntaran,
por ejemplo, por qué no estoy a favor de bombardear Japón,
bueno, sólo bromeo a medias cuando digo que porque los japoneses construyeron mi auto.
Existe esta relación suma no nula entre nosotros,
y creo que ello lleva a un tipo de tolerancia hasta el punto que descubrimos
que el bienestar de otros está directamente relacionado con el tuyo.
Hay más posibilidades de que les demos un respiro.
Creo que es un tipo de moralidad de "primera clase".
Desgraciadamente no viajo lo suficiente en primera en vuelos transatlánticos
o en cualquier otro tipo de primera clase como para saberlo.
Pero supongo que en primera no se escuchan muchas expresiones de, bueno,
intolerancia hacia grupos raciales o étnicos,
porque los pasajeros que van en primera en vuelos transatlánticos
hacen negocios con toda esta gente; están haciendo dinero
de sus relaciones con esta gente. Y sinceramente creo que, al menos
en ese sentido, el capitalismo ha sido una fuerza constructiva
y, en esencia, es una suma no nula
que ha servido constructivamente para expandir el espectro de
conciencia moral de las personas. Creo que la dinámica de suma no nula,
que no es sólo económica ni de lejos, no es siempre comercio,
pero que nos ha llevado al borde de una verdad moral,
es la igualdad esencial de todas las personas. Ha logrado eso.
Y al pasar a ser global, nos ha llevado a un nivel global de organización social,
nos ha llevado hacia una verdad moral.
Eso me parece maravilloso.
Ahora, volviendo al apocalipsis en desarrollo.
Y pueden preguntarse, bueno, todo eso está bien,
suena bien, un sentido moral en la historia,
¿pero qué sucede con el llamado choque de civilizaciones? Bueno, primero
enfatizaría que este choque calza con una estructura de suma no nula.
Si ustedes ven la relación
entre el llamado mundo musulmán y el mundo occidental,
dos términos que me desagradan, pero que realmente no puedo evitar usar
en un período de tiempo tan breve, pues al menos son eficientes.
Eso es una suma no nula. Y con ello me refiero a que
si las personas del mundo musulmán tuvieran más odio, más resentimiento,
si fueran menos felices con su lugar en el mundo,
sería malo para Occidente. Si están más contentos, será bueno para Occidente.
Y eso es una dinámica de suma no nula.
Y diría que esta dinámica de suma no nula sólo se va a intensificar más con el tiempo
por las tendencias tecnológicas, pero más intensa de forma negativa.
Lo que será cada vez más posible es una correlación inversa de sus destinos.
Y una razón es algo que llamo la letalidad creciente del odio.
Progresivamente, el odio arraigado en el extranjero
se manifestará como violencia organizada en suelo estadounidense.
Y eso es algo bastante nuevo, y creo que esta capacidad empeorará
mucho debido a una
tecnología de la información pasajera, en tecnologías que podrán ser usadas
para fines armamentistas como la biotecnología y la nanotecnología.
Puede que empecemos a oír más sobre este asunto ahora.
Y hay algo que me preocupa especialmente, y es que esta
dinámica llevará a una especie de ciclo retroalimentador que nos meterá en apuros.
Lo que pienso es: el terrorismo ocurre acá; y en respuesta sobrereaccionamos.
Que, bueno, no somos lo suficientemente precisos en nuestras represalias
y eso desemboca en más odio en el exterior, más terrorismo.
Exageramos porque somos humanos, sentimos la necesidad de tomar represalias,
y todo empeora más y más y más.
A esto se le podría llamar retroalimentación positiva ante vibraciones negativas,
pero pienso en algo tan horripilante
que la palabra "positiva" no debería asociársele, ni siquiera en sentido técnico.
Entonces llamémosle la espiral mortal de negatividad.
(Risas)
Les aseguro que si ocurre, al final, tanto Occidente
como el mundo musulmán habrá sufrido. OK.
Entonces, ¿qué hacemos? Pues en primer lugar podemos hacer mucho más con el control de armas,
la regulación internacional de tecnologías peligrosas.
Tengo un sermón entero sobre gobierno global
que ahora evitaré predicarles,
porque no creo que fuera suficiente, si bien es esencial.
Sí creo que habrá un giro importante
en el progreso moral del mundo.
Creo que veremos menos odio entre grupos,
menos intelorencia y, bueno, grupos raciales o religiosos, u otros.
Debo admitir que me siento algo tonto diciéndolo.
Suena como algo exageradamente optimista. Me siento como Rodney King, saben,
diciéndo, ¿por qué no podemos todos llevarnos bien?
Pero A: realmente no veo alternativa, considerando cómo veo la situación.
Vale, tendrá que haber progreso moral.
Tendrá que haber una disminución de todo el odio en el mundo,
considerando lo peligroso que se está volviendo.
A mi favor diría, que por muy ingenuo que esto suene,
que en realidad está basado en el cinismo.
Esto es,
(Risas)
gracias, gracias. Esto es, recuerden: toda mi visión
sobre la moralidad se reduce al egoísmo.
Sucede cuando el destino de la gente está relacionado.
Sucede que cuando tu bienestar conduce al mío, entonces yo decido, claro,
que estoy totalmente en favor de tu bienestar. Ésa es la causa
del crecimiento de este progreso moral hasta ahora,
y digo nuevamente que nosotros tenemos destinos relacionados.
Y si la gente responde a ello de forma inteligente, veremos
el desarrollo de la tolerancia y así sucesivamente...
ya saben, las reglas que necesitamos.
Veremos una evolución más profunda de ese tipo de moralidad de Primera Clase.
Así que, ya saben, si estas dos cosas captan la atención de la gente,
enfatizan su correlación positiva y la gente actúa en su interés propio,
que es profundizar la evolución moral,
entonces podrían realmente obtener un efecto constructivo.
Y ésa es la razón por la que agrupo la creciente letalidad del odio
con la espiral mortal de negatividad bajo el epígrafe general:
razones para ser optimista.
(Risas)
Bueno, hago lo que puedo.
Nunca me he considerado Don Optimista.
Sólo hago lo que puedo.
(Risas)
Ahora, iniciar una revolución moral debe de ser difícil, ¿no?
Es decir, ¿qué hay que hacer?
Y creo que la respuesta es que muchas personas diferentes
tendrán que hacer muchas cosas distintas.
Todos empezamos donde estamos. Hablando como estadounidense,
preocupado por la seguridad de mis hijos de los próximos 10, 20, 30 años,
personalmente lo que quiero empezar a hacer
es entender por qué tanta gente en el mundo nos odia.
Creo que es un valioso proyecto de investigación.
También me gusta porque intrínsicamente es un ejercicio de redención moral,
porque para entender por qué alguien
en una cultura muy distinta hace algo,
alguien a quien se ve como extraño,
que hace cosas que consideras extrañas,
en una cultura que consideras extraña, para realmente entender por qué hacen
las cosas que hacen es un logro moralmente redentor
porque debes relacionar su experiencia con la tuya.
Para entenderlo realmente, debes decir, "Oh, ya entiendo.
Así cuando sienten resentimiento, es igual que
cuando yo siento resentimiento en estos casos,
y al parecer por las mismas razones". Eso es verdadero entendimiento.
Y creo que cuando consigues hacer eso, tu brújula moral se expande.
Vale, es especialmente difícil hacerlo con gente que te odia,
porque realmente no quieres
entender del todo porqué la gente te odia.
Es decir, quieres oír la razón, pero no quieres poder identificarte con ella.
No quieres que tenga sentido, ¿no?
No quieres decir: "Bueno, claro, creo que entiendo
cómo un ser humano en esas circunstancias
podría odiar el país en que vivo." No es un tema agradable,
pero creo que es algo a lo que tendremos que acostumbrarnos y
en lo que habrá que trabajar. Auiero enfatizar que para entender, ya saben,
hay gente a la que no le gusta todo este asunto del entendimiento,
la raíz, la causa principal de las cosas; ellos no quieren saber
porqué la gente nos odia. Yo quiero entenderlo.
La razón por la que tratas de entender porqué nos odian,
es para lograr que dejen de odiarnos, OK. La idea
cuando efectúas este ejercicio moral de realmente llegar a apreciar
su humanidad y entenderlos mejor, es parte de un esfuerzo
para lograr que ellos aprecien tu humanidad a largo plazo.
Creo que es el primer paso hacia ello. Ésa es la meta a largo plazo.
Hay gente que se preocupa por esto y, de hecho,
yo mismo, aparentemente, fui denunciado en la TV nacional
hace un par de noches por una columna de opinión que escribí.
La denuncia estaba relacionada con esto, y la afirmación era
que yo tengo, y cito, "afecto por los terroristas".
La buena noticia es que la autora de esa denuncia fue Ann Coulter.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Es decir, si tienes que tener un enemigo, que sea Ann Coulter.
(Risas)
Pero no es una preocupación descabellada, porque entender el comportamiento
puede conducir a una especie de empatía,
y eso puede dificultar que uno haga críticas constructivas, y así sucesivamente.
Pero creo que estamos mucho más de cerca de errar por no comprender
la situación claramente, que de comprenderla tan claramente
que no podamos, ya saben, sacar al ejército a matar terroristas.
No me preocupa demasiado.Así que...
(Risas)
tendremos que trabajar mucho en varios frentes.
Pero si lo logramos, si tenemos éxito, entonces nuevamente,
la suma no nula y el reconocimiento de las dinámicas de suma no nula
nos habrán empujado hacia un nivel moral superior.
Y un tipo de nivel moral superior que nos salvará,
algo que literalmente podría salvar el mundo.
Si analizan la palabra "salvación" en la Biblia,
la acepción cristiana que nos es familiar:
el salvar almas, que las personas vayan al cielo... esa acepción es tardía.
La acepción original de la palabra en la Biblia se refiere a salvar el sistema social.
"Jehovah es nuestro Salvador," significa "Él ha salvado a la nación de Israel"
la que en esos tiempos, era una organzación social de nivel bastante alto.
Ahora, la organización social ha alcanzado nivel global, y supongo que
si hay buenas noticias que pueda darles, es que
toda lo que la salvación del mundo requiere es la búsqueda inteligente
de intereses propios de una forma disciplinada y cuidadosa.
Será difícil. Les propongo que igualmente lo intentemos
porque hemos avanzado demasiado como para arruinarlo todo ahora.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)